[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
happy tuesday everyone
great to be in nashville at the
listening room once again and we got
some great guests judge jeanine is here
you know
she drove all the way from new york
here here she is pulling into the
parking lot
[Music]
yeah
the judge loves to speed i asked her why
and she said greg i treat the road like
it's death row put on that seat belt
step on the gas
and i didn't get a ticket
and look it's larry gatlin
of the country music legends the gatlin
brothers
i gotta tell you did those guys party
back in the day the gatlin brothers they
inhaled more white powder than a baby's
butt
yeah they were a wild bunch back in the
70s
now they're in their 70s
now they cut their coke with lipitor
they've replaced orgies with orthopedics
prostitutes with proctologists
no more smoking joints they're replacing
them
but it's great to see larry known for
the classic hit all the gold in
california
yeah
all the
all the gold in california larry should
update the song to reflect today all the
poop on my shoe in california
yeah if those streets got any filthier
they'd be jessie's hairbrush
or cat's vocabulary
sadly california dreaming is now a guy
sleeping in a tent in your front lawn
throwing up on your porch
a shout out to sean penn
but speak speaking of cat uh she had a
great first night out in nashville
yes
you're a queen
[Music]
i keep telling cat i go hold back it's
only monday we got a whole week here
and she said oh you're right greg i'll
save the rest of this moonshine for my
cereal
then there's tyrus
[Music]
uh i'll just move on
so remember when we were told the adults
were taking back government when joe
biden won yet they ousted orange
godzilla and we got the creature from
the black lagoon
yep
pretty amazing
yeah that's that's some normalcy we got
there's serious bedlam going on at the
border there are thousands still
converging many are sick and like
hillary crime remains unchecked and
unprosecuted
perhaps 100 americans may still be in
afghanistan inflation rising like
hunter's heart rate after a pull on his
crack pipe
control yourself larry it's just a
picture
so it's a lot of bad news the upside is
i still look great it's
true it's amazing for a man in his early
40s
but thank
it's not that funny judge
but thankfully despite all this bad news
we have an adult in charge
okay an adult a guy in an adult diaper
captain joe look at him aviator
sunglasses
check
bomber jacket check
he looks like someone crossed a delta
pilot with arthur fonzarelli
too bad his microphone gets cut more
than me trying to make the eighth grade
soccer team
this year i was closer than ever
seriously i feel like a guest at
epstein's island where are the adults we
were promised
i seem to remember being told in my
mandated anger management classes that
an adult takes responsibility for his
actions but here's joe responding to his
recent crisis
take a look at what i inherited when i
came into office
when i came into office the state of
affairs and where we were
we had four million people vaccinated we
had no plan we had i mean i could go
down the list i'm not complaining it's
just a reality
i'm not
not complaining it's just the reality
this guy wouldn't recognize reality if
the entire cast of duck dynasty bit him
in the ass
which i paid for
so what is this reality how about that
anyone vaccinated today can thank
something called operation warp speed
created some by someone named trump
[Applause]
how's that for red meat
biden's reality blame everyone for every
mistake you make and not only blame the
last guy in office but also decent
americans like the guy who was just
trying to steer his horse
yeah joe biden punishes border patrol
forget this patrolling the border
what's next punished strippers for
stripping
soldiers for soldiering
the police for policing
oh wait we already do that
but you notice this trend that people
doing their jobs are being punished by
people who don't so you have an
incompetent president trashing the
people cleaning up his mistakes at the
border you have a media demonizing the
cops who try to protect its society that
the media tries to tear apart
and the media still whines over using
horses to navigate uneven terrain well
what should they be using
segways
that's for malls
maybe the critics should ask why the
border patrol is needed
because
there's no wall you jackasses
think about that by the way
walls don't need horses
and i respect joe if he admits he
wrongly smeared that guy and apologizes
but i won't hold my breath mainly
because if i do i'd look like a smurf
so
so build back better it's stupidest
slogan ever
sounds like a leftover from a labor day
sale at home depot
the only thing joe builds is blame he
pretends to take responsibility saying
the buck stops with me as he passes more
bucks than a guy who eats dollar bills
so
i wonder if blaming the past really
works in real life
ugh this place is such a mess i am so
sick of this whoa stop blaming me it's
not my fault it's your exes oh yeah and
there's never any food in the fridge
it's not my fault it's your ex you are
such a slob it's
your ex stop blaming my ex for literally
everything well he's literally right
over there
[Music]
[Applause]
you leave him alone okay we're in love
that should be a sitcom
so as america lurches backward what's
joe got to say for himself come on man
don't give me that
absent leadership i am present man i am
present
and accounted for
i don't know where i am right now
actually i tell you what happens is what
they drive me places
and then i get out and i i read what
they tell me and then i no no questions
no question then i get back in the car
they drive me someplace else
it works out man
oh just got dark
but i i know where i am
the good news about america this
country's so strong that we can
withstand a bumbling old man who like a
35 year old unemployed millennial living
with his parents refuses to bear any
responsibility but are we strong enough
to endure the woksters who control him
they're like kids going after their rich
dad's estate before he passes
but hey at least he bravely went on
national tv to get his booster shot
let's roll that tape
okay there we go nothing to worry about
boost your shot
oh
that didn't go over too well
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guests
yeah you should hear her outdoor voice
host of justice with judge janine
he's given us more great singles than a
search on match.com country singer and
songwriter larry gatlin
chill sing standby you're a man right
before she shoves him into traffic fox
news contributor cat tim
and he's so huge his flight landed at
305 pm 306 pm and 308 pm
my massive sidekick and the nwa world tv
champion
tyrus
how's it going judge
doing all right i'm doing okay yeah you
look great man that leopard's dead but
he's happy he died for this yes
well he died for you he died for you
you're wearing that for me
yeah and everybody here i'm in nashville
you are how they trust in nashville
all right
stop going for the easy applause lines
judge that's what i do
it's great to be here in nashville
anyway
anyway judge okay shouldn't leaders set
an example an embraced responsibility
what's going on with our president
nothing
no how can he set an example he doesn't
know what he's doing i mean i call him
the liar in chief i mean we have a
commander-in-chief he's a liar in chief
he said there was no real vaccine
nothing nobody was vaccinated when he
got there there was no plan the truth is
there were three vaccines that were
moved at warp speed by donald trump
there was a plan he said only 4 million
people were vaccinated 17 million were
vaccinated there was a plan in
afghanistan he gets out 13 of our
soldiers are killed he says it's an
extraordinary success the man's out of
his mind he has no idea what reality is
or what or what you know reality is yes
i repeated myself you did i did it
it bears repeating liars losers and
leaders liberals liars liberals liars
liberals and leakers
liars lions
out of the constitution sorry no it's
not nowhere larry can you imagine doing
this at work if you actually do work i
don't know if you're working these days
but but uh you know when you say like oh
it's the other guy's fault what does
that make you feel how does that make
you feel by the way it's great to see
you great to see you my friend welcome i
like your shirt thank you did you see
the under it yeah that's what i'm
talking about
songwriters matter
songwriters
you're applauding a racist shirt but go
ahead well
i'll answer your question in a minute
but a songwriter a great songwriter
george frederick root
wrote the song many years ago it goes
red and yellow black and white they are
precious in this light jesus loves the
little children of them where am i
guessing
[Applause]
hey and great and so do i larry you're
you're eating into your talk time
you're eating into your talk time you
now you only have one point you can make
and it's got to be a really good one
because that singing
okay
we all we all know about all of the
things judge was talking about uh
socrates asked the questions he didn't
answer him so i'm going to ask one
question right how many of you fathers
mothers grandmothers grandfathers would
give the keys to your car and your house
to joe biden to protect your kids or
grandkids one dog and watch the house
while you went on vacation for two days
to florida if you would do that say yeah
if you wouldn't give him the keys say no
but he has the keys he has the keys to
the uh
nuclear football cat
uh do you think biden will actually
build anything back better
no uh and the complaining doesn't make
sense because everyone inherits a mess
in some way or another like is isn't
that what marriage is right your second
husband is going to feel my husband
inherited a mess like
i i've been burned in the past i still
have issues that affect me now he
doesn't complain about it because he
knows he's very lucky to be married to a
national treasure of course yes
he would be sleeping on the couch the
only people who complain about it are
modern politicians i say modern
politicians because it's not like
abraham lincoln was complaining about
how he inherited a mess throughout the
civil war yes like could you imagine if
the gettysburg address began like four
scoring seven years ago was when all
this started so this is like totally not
my fault so don't blame me like
that's not quite as inspiring right he
did it he focused on bringing people
together and go you know solutions to
problems and not making about himself
whether we blame for it because that's
what a leader is supposed to do there
you go
all right
i if if joe biden was actually president
i probably wouldn't worry as much but i
feel like he's just the hood ornament to
a very dangerous woke machine
we have to check under the hood and see
what's there you go ahead i don't have
to look under the hood and know the
engine's gone um
can we please from the remainder of my
time could we put the greg smurf up
i will that was amazing because i feel
like it wasn't much photoshop in there
but actually i was taller in that
picture oh yeah you were it was good and
a little buffer too nice job yeah there
it is that it right there is magic yes
and as unbelievable as that is it's
right up there with thinking that
president joe biden knows what's going
on right now
better chance of that smurf jumping out
and balancing the budget than anything
going on in the office right now do you
imagine waking up to that just sitting
on your chest i don't know what
[Laughter]
is your wife here
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else